♪♪
Ian:
Gandi.
Eleanor Roosevelt.
Nelson Mandela.
Henry Ford...these are leaders
who trusted their inner voice.
Oh you’ve got to be kidding me.
♪♪
Mythic Quest is way better off
without them.
Damn straight.
This is our masterpiece.
(Clapping)
We did it! We really did it!
Yes!
♪♪
David:
MQ’s doing well.
I know you guys didn’t think I
could do it.
No no, we, I mean we literally
haven’t said your name in a
year.
Oh.
♪♪
Carol:
I’d like to introduce you to our
newest employee.
I’m glad you’re back.
You know as janitor I see a lot
of things, but you have nothing
to worry about.
Brad:
There’s nothing like strange or
nefarious going on.
That’s some Illuminati.
And even if there was you’d
never know it.
Um... sorry, wait, what?
♪♪
He’s always wanted to bring MQ
to Hollywood, but I’m the first
one to pull it off.
How could I not even be
consulted on it?
My DNA is literally all over
that game.
Gross.
♪ work it out, work it out,
work, work, work it out.♪
(Laughing)
♪♪
Joe Manganiello? No one’s gonna
believe that he can play me, he’s
not big enough!
David:
He’s like 6’4”.
-6’5”.
♪♪
You have made a huge mistake.
Ian Elizabeth Grimm!
I’m building an entire game from
scratch and you’re pacing around
in the Metaverse.
(Crying)
I totally get it, I had to work
with those wackos too.
♪♪
(Laughing)
Carol:
Y’all are cray-cray.
Ba-nay-nay.
(Screaming)
♪♪
Yeah!
(Screaming)
Poppy:
Post-it notes are a part of my
system.
Why can’t you just be a normal
person and just take notes in
your phone?
Because like a normal person I
lost my phone ages ago and now
Dana takes my calls for me.
Don't nobody call you.
♪♪